COLT MCANLIS: This week, we're
talking about the AutoML Tables
SDK, the new Kubernetes
Benchmark, and Anthos training.
I'm Colt McAnlis, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Google Cloud AutoML
offers tools and resources
to help you build the machine
learning models that you need.
And now, the AutoML Tables
SDK brings those tools
to your own application by
triggering or automating
each step of the process.
Check out this
example, which shows
how to use the SDK end-to-end
within a Jupyter Notebook.
The Center for Internet
Security provides a set
of Kubernetes security best
practices with their Kubernetes
benchmark.
And the latest version
was just released.
So we've released a new CIS
Google Kubernetes Engine
benchmark to take the guesswork
out of which recommendations
you should check out and which
ones we've already checked out
for you.
And when it comes to
keeping you covered,
we know that customers rely
on Google Cloud Support
to be seamless, simple,
and straightforward.
So we're adding a new
proactive option to our lineup.
Premium support offers
context-aware experts
that understand your
architecture and work
hand-in-hand with your
technical account manager
to solve your problems.
Anthos is Google Cloud's
open-application modernization
platform and can
help your apps become
more portable, maintainable,
scalable, and secure.
We've just released a new
learning specialization
designed for infrastructure
operators, architects,
and DevOps called Architecting
Hybrid Cloud Infrastructure
with Anthos.
Give it a try.
Let us know what you think.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see the full list,
check out the links
in the description and below.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment
or send us a tweet
and we'll see you in the cloud.